en france revenons à présent à angers
depuis la découverte de ce sordide
réseau de pédophilie neuf personnes au
total ont été mises en examen
plus l'enquêté avance plus les coeurs
mans s'installe on compte 27 victimes et
même des bébés de 6 mois
françois privat filles et prixtel s'est
notamment au domicile de franck et
patricia vergon dit dans cette résidence
de l'agglomération angevine que
plusieurs enfants ont été régulièrement
victimes d'actes de pédophilie
les faits se dérouler le samedi
après-midi les concernent aussi des
enfants d'amis ou de voisins
selon l'avocate de patricia bergon dit
le couple a perçu de l'argent
elle a expliqué qu'elle était rémunéré
mais pas au début des faits simplement
une partie d'une certaine période et que
cet argent transitaient et c'était
quelques fois son mari s'il recevait
mais quelquefois elle elle a indiqué
qu'elle recevait peu près 1000 à 2000
francs par semaine on a à peu près
établi une soixantaine de sel après
trois nouvelles mises en examen ces
derniers jours huit personnes sont
écrouées
certaines ici à la maison d'arrêt
d'angers selon le parquet cette affaire
de pédophilie concerne désormais 27
enfants âgés de 6 mois à 12 ans il y
avait également des sommes d'argent
versées en liquide et ce sera bien sûr
l'objectif de l'instruction dans les
semaines et les mois à venir que
d'identifier certains clients
la brigade des mineurs du srpj d'angers
chargés de l'enquète devrait procéder à
de nouvelles interpellations dans la
semaine prochaine